you say green beer or green beer oh that
too
green beer i would say green beer i like
that you're reading a story uh-huh but
you can get that dog in your peripheral
this is totally different wait a minute
yeah she'll be reading because i think i
see in my peripheral i think i see a
retriever yes in fact if we had a
retriever in this this tower cam she'd
spot it from my miles away that's how
you you dial it yeah it's almost like
her super power it's absolutely you have
spiderman you have superman she's like i
feel like there's 20 dogs in this room
right now yes let me sniff him out she
can retrieve the retriever
uh great shot outside from her tower cam
showing those high clouds doesn't look
like yesterday we had all that sunshine
today lots of clouds out there at this
hour that's going to keep us from
actually reaching our official high of
80 degrees i think that the numbers
haven't officially come in yet because
remember we're now at an hour longer all
right so that's going to give us another
hour or two before we actually reach our
actual higher they show us our high poly
report again ash elm and mulberry
reporting very high readings right now
this again is going to be the issue as
we get through spring here with the
pollen all blooming and the winds also
kicking up that pollen too right now 72
to 10 hills along with summerlin with 74
for the lake 75 for you downtown 78
green valley 74 also for spring valley
roads ranch mountains at 75
we're at 79 for seven hills and 81
southern highlands right now outside of
town here you go 73 for prompt 81 for
death valley and warmer view in laflin
at 86 degrees currently so nothing on
the radar unfortunately but i threw in
the satellite here because you can see
the thicker cloud cover coming in from
west to east and this cloud cover is
going to be around tonight one thing
that we'll do though is keep our
temperatures on the warm side tonight
and also tomorrow morning too what we're
watching is the ridge that was over is
now moving off towards the midwest
that's why bismarck is in the 60s right
now cooler air within this trough we're
going to see that tomorrow and also for
st patrick's day here's your wind
forecast we're expecting for tomorrow so
it will be a breezy day tomorrow we'll
keep around some of those breezes for
thursday but not as strong and then that
break on friday before another system
rolls in this weekend and gives us gusty
winds i think the stronger winds will be
this weekend and we're even throwing in
slight shower chances also for when
sunday specifically shower chances have
gone up
we'll keep our eye on that not only that
but it's also the first day of spring 56
degrees tonight evening clouds and then
clearing overnight your high tomorrow 77
degrees breezy and warm marlin this
we're back to sunshine and looks look at
our normal will be above normal and
gusts like we said up to 30 for tomorrow
throughout many of our neighborhoods
highs tomorrow mid to high 70s similar
what we saw for the day today we'll see
that outside of town to actually warmer
for you and death valley you 89 degrees
tomorrow 74 for prom here is your eight
day forecast notice the temperatures
again they go up they go down they go up
and down again it's just this time of
the year march and april we see that
we'll also see those chances for showers
on sunday which happens to be the first
day of spring like we talked about and
we'll be breezy to windy on several days
in this eight day that's your most
accurate forecast right